Oh my god.
Bro, oh my fucking god.
I did not realize just how oh my This game I'll just say
like this fucking game
Holy shit, this fucking game.
Oh my god.
The amount of hoops I have to jump to get this.
Guys, I'm so sorry that we're an hour late.
I'm so sorry.
This, it was, it was hell.
It truly was hell.
I tried to get this game to work.
Oh, that's all I'll say.
Was it worth it?
I don't know.
I mean, it's so cute though.
Okay, I need to tell you guys the story.
I'm so sorry.
We're an hour late.
I went through a whole fucking adventure Trying to get this
to work, but I hope the volume's okay right now.
I hope the volume's okay Um, you know, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
A certified apple moment.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you normal size fandom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, doki wasn't worth it?
All right.
So god this song is so fucking like All right, let me tell
you guys like the How this whole shit went through so Oh,
you can bring down the music a little okay I'm gonna like
I'm like really worried Because I didn't manage to create a
new account So I'm gonna be very careful right now I'm gonna
let me let me turn this off real quick
So okay, so I'm gonna turn down the the music right?
Okay, bring down the music a little bit.
Okay, I'm gonna bring down the music a little bit.
I'm like a paranoid as hell, right?
So, anyway, let me tell you the adventure.
I had to have my own little adventure that I had to have
before we were able to get all of this to work.
So, my little adventure is that basically what happened was
that I woke up and I was like,
What happened was that?
I realized, I was like, wait a minute, because I don't know,
this must be an old iPad.
Because I was like, I was like, I don't need to.
I was like, oh, man, I don't need to have a, I don't need to
have a new iPad.
You know, I have so much streaming experience.
I can just use, because I don't have an iPad.
I use my dad's iPad.
need an new iPad I'll just borrow my parents iPad because
iPads are so fucking expensive what I didn't realize is that
um this is ever is this like a particularly old iPad you
know it's a particularly old iPad because the adapter the
iPad adapter is still like um the adapter is still USB-C
it's not a lightning adapter you know it was before when
Apple you know it was before when everything using the
lightning adapter like like made everything so you know it's
old when the iPad is still using USB-C before the Apple was
like no uh-uh we're gonna make everything um lightning so so
I didn't realize I didn't have the adapter for the for to
use for the game capture because I was like oh yeah I can
just uh I can just, you know, I'll just use this, this game
capture adapter that I have for my iPhone, that I use to
stream with my iPhone.
And then I was like, wait a minute.
Why doesn't it fit?
Oh, I met the 30 pin.
Sorry.
The 30 pin.
I don't remember.
It's one of them.
Okay, it's one of them.
I don't remember.
Okay, so, um, anyway, um, I just know that like the one I
have is not does not work because like it doesn't fit into
the one because it I was like okay so I need to I need to
buy I need to go to I need to go to an electronic store and
buy an adapter because I was like oh I'll just use my
android adapter you know yeah the one when I had the android
pad I don't know what do they call the i android iPad do
just call it the android tablet sorry i'll just use the
android tablet to um because i have the adapter to to stream
my android tablet because this game is an apple exclusive by
the way i hope the sound's okay i turned down the sound on
my end oh there was no sound there's no music at all you
just hear the fucking ambience never mind uh never mind
anyway so um i was like all right I have an adapter for
Android tablets and like my cable for the iPad fits an
Android tablet So I'll use the Android tablet adapter to you
to plug into my game capture that would work right So it
didn't um I would kept crashing the the game captured kept
crashing because who would have thought uh it didn't work so
uh so I was like okay we gotta go to the electronic store
and like we gotta go to the electronics store and buy the
adapter the Apple you know like because you know the Apple
approved adapter that can connect to the game capture so I
bought that and then I came back and I was like alright good
we should be able to stream now and then I was like wait a
minute I can't buy any games because this account is you
know my dad's account password so i was like okay uh i'm
gonna log out and create a new account and then it wouldn't
let me it wouldn't let me put in a phone number it wouldn't
let me put in the phone number to create a new account it
wouldn't let me do like two factor it wouldn't let me like
sync a payment to it so i was like okay i'm just gonna log
into my dad's account i was like dad what's the password and
he was like
no i don't know what the password is so i was like okay it's
a yahoo account dad do you remember he's like i don't
fucking know who uses yahoo anymore and i was like oh no my
ipad went to sleep oh no okay it's gonna be a black screen
until my ipad's not sleeping anyway anyway um i was like
okay then uh then why don't you like uh like can you like
log like he's like no and then i can't log out because i
need the password to log out so so so and then i was like
okay what if i log out on the itunes store on the itunes app
store and and then and then um i'll log in to my accounts or
like to like your other account he's like oh yeah i have
another account you can log into and then so i logged into
the other dad account that he has that's a not a yahoo
account because he actually has access to it and then and
then we realized that his gmail account is um his his gmail
account is not registered in na so the store for those who
don't know hello kitty island adventure is a is an apple
exclusive and it's also only in na or like i don't
definitely not in asia
it's it's definitely not in So I was like, oh fuck.
Okay.
Now they'll figure out that I'll change the store country
the country of the store So I changed the country of the
store and then I changed it But then they're like well, we
need a payment card for Canada So I was like, all right,
I'll just put my cards on and they're like we can't verify
this payment I was like, okay, I'll just use PayPal and
they're like we can't verify this either and I was like,
okay I fucking
So, so yeah, we it was region locked to a specific region So
I was like okay, and then my dad literally was like oh my
god We have your we have access to the yahoo account Because
like they were like look my dad and mom were looking through
like various because like okay Um, um, they've been they've
been using apple phones for a long time since apple iPhones
were since iPhones were like first introduced when an iPhone
was made of metal Was it metal it was like I remember like
the very first iPhone was like metal and it was like super
heavy and all that so like they were just looking through
their collections of iPhones and one of them still had the
yahoo account registered to the iphone to the to the iphone
so they're like we got it we got access to the iphone we got
access to the yahoo man because they were looking through
like the collection of phones and like one of the phones one
of the phones slash ipads had access like had little access
to the to the yahoo account so we were able to change the
password and they're like you change it since you're gonna
use it you use the password for it and then so then i had to
change the password and then now and then i finally i i
bought hella kitty island adventure i bought hella kitty oh
my god it was truly a fucking adventure to actually get
started playing hallow kitty island adventure and oh my god
it was so painful i was like i couldn't believe we had to go
through so much just to play this fucking game did you write
i wrote the pastor the struggles we go through for hallow
kitty razzy-dazzy thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it really was a fucking journey to get here just
to play this fucking game anyway for those who are like what
is hella kitty island adventure it's essentially like it's
essentially like uh animal crossing but instead of like
animal crossing characters it's just all samuel characters
and it's but it's only on the on the apples like apple apple
devices apparently you play on the mac and everything
I think the only people who use Mac, I'm so sorry to all the
Mac users, but I feel like the only people who use like Mac,
Mac, Macs anymore are like video editors and video audio
editors or yeah, I guess like normies, I guess, but I don't
know.
Same here.
I don't know who buys a Mac anymore but i know a lot of like
video audio editors still use the mac for like stuff there i
guess so uh but yes it's sadly only an apple exclusive and
it really was so painful to get here all right here we go
i'm like all right yay want to go fishing basmaru can teach
you to make a fishing rod Yay!
We're loading!
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of this, like, thumb thing over
here.
Alright, it's gonna bother you.
It might bother you guys a little bit, but I'm just gonna...
Oh, you're awake.
Hi there!
I'm Hello Kitty!
Please, don't dox my family.
Hello Kitty, please let me fill in my own name.
That's all I asked, Miss Kitty.
That's all I asked of you.
Okay.
All right.
Are you ready for a vacation at Big Adventures Park?
Yes.
Uh, yes.
We should be arriving soon, so we want to freshen up.
But now is the time.
Oh my God.
Hello Kitty.
fan i you know guys i'm gonna say i think i think she's
overrated i think it was super chat thank you thank you
doctor thank you with super chat thank you thank you your
life is in her hands now oh my god when your entire life is
in the kitty's hands all right i'm gonna i don't know i
don't Oh, thank God.
Oh, my God.
It's so cute.
I'm basically you dragons.
I don't think I have to change anything.
I know.
Oh, my God.
I actually just don't have to change anything.
Okay, wait, let's see.
Maybe the eyes, maybe.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is the dragon hairstyle.
Wait, this is literally the dragon hairstyle.
Right?
Yeah, it's like this.
And then...
Okay, wait.
I actually like that.
Wait, this or...
Wait, actually, either this...
Oh, no, this.
Actually, or this.
Wait, they're all so good!
Instead of doxing me, I dox you guys.
Okay, wait, they're all so fucking good!
Okay, I don't know.
Oh my gosh, I can't.
They're all so cute.
Need the stupid eyes?
Which one's the stupid eyes?
They're all pretty dumb.
They're all pretty dumb, though.
Which one's the stupid ones?
Alright.
Maybe...
I did this or...
This.
I don't know.
Okay.
Left, right.
One, two.
Which one, guys?
One or two, guys.
One, two.
One...
What?
This?
This one?
Okay.
One, two, three.
two three which one chat one two three two okay i see more
twos all right beaks oh that's like a duck beak okay this
one is that's an eagle i feel like this or this did i break
it oh i'm gonna say i think maybe this one looks more like a
dragon this one and then what is this oh it's like the face
markings.
Okay, I think this one definitely.
Alright, I think we got it.
Can we change clothes?
Oh, we can.
Okay, sorry, I just thought.
Okay, let's see.
No hats, because we can't afford hats right now.
Alright, I think, I think, wait, should we give you a, this
shirt or a green shirt?
Guys.
Damn.
Raw.
black shirt you guys want a black shirt we meant three okay
five oh wait no shirt no shirt this one you want this no
three wait i don't want you guys to wear a shirt wait can i
not yet
nice okay this this is good
all right okay we're good i think this is perfect i think
honestly i think this is perfect yes yes the the pure
dragoon um dragoon uncut right there the no filter dragoon
right here okay this is it this is what what is there what
am i exposing you have nothing what am i exposing there's
literally nothing dragoons there's nothing finally dragoon
cheek talks are real super chat thank you thank you my eyes
are up there ladies all right accept yay you look great oh
my gosh thank you miss kitty if you want to change your
appearance later you can do so at any time at a mirror okay
nice we don't know you guys are perfect right there i think
you're perfect just as the way you look like what you guys
never wore any pants even before
worn a shirt but never any pants what are you exposing right
now nothing we saw some time you can meet others on our
flight if you like to come talk to me you feel like you're
you're done chatting okay oh my god look press to move okay
move talk to some of the passengers okay do i oh i'm right
here but like okay here oh my god Look, I'm moving.
I'm naked.
You're naked.
Hello.
Talk to me.
Tuxedo Sam.
Greetings and salutations.
Tuxedo Sam, at your service.
An honor.
Nice to meet you.
Making new friends is always delightful and quite inspiring.
You see, I'm both a designer and collect...
Oh, they're gonna let me give me clothes later.
We don't need clothes, though.
CJ, thank you for the service.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
We love you, Doki.
Cool and cute.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Please don't hesitate to ask.
Okay, this is the guy we're never gonna talk to.
Because, like, we're never gonna need clothes.
Nothing makes me happier than helping my friends look their
best.
If you excuse me, I feel inspiration about to strike.
Alright.
I wanna talk to Karomi.
Are you still talking to new friends?
Or do you wanna meet them?
No, I'm still chatting.
Wait, I wanna talk to Karomi!
Wait, I can jump.
too?
Oh my god.
Karomi!
Let me bother you!
Hey, how are you?
I can't wait to see the island.
Oh, this is like the animal crossing in the beginning where
you're talking to people before you arrive in the town.
The name's Karomi.
Don't believe anything.
Those two jokers, batsmodern, Karopi, say about me.
Yeah, they're all wrong.
You're always right, Miss, my queen.
I see you notice my book.
I've been collecting vintage tickets, posters, and pretty
much anything I could find from this place sometimes i
didn't even think it was real like maybe it was an elaborate
hoax so i decided to film an episode of my show karomi
explains it all oh my god she's famous of course she is
she's a queen but my melisak could just enjoy myself don't
listen to that bitch i'm just hoping wiki swamps lives up to
his reputation do what you want to do my queen all right uh
cj What will hella kid?
You think she loves it?
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Get out of the way.
I'm talking.
No, get out of the way.
I only want to talk to one person.
Get out of the way.
I want to talk to Papa Puran.
I don't care about you.
I don't care about you, Puchi, whatever.
Oh my god.
That's, um, Ritsi.
Oh my gosh.
I can't remember how to say your name.
Ritsiko.
I don't know.
I was like thinking about the, like, the show's name.
I haven't watched the two seasons of Retsuko yet Agusuko
Miss Flight Like you Okay so spoiler alert There was a scene
Where like she gets dumped And then she settles for this
other guy And then I was so mad That I never watched I never
I didn't watch the season after I was so I was so mad I was
like Why did you settle for him It's a fucking loser I
I'm sorry for all those all those people that actually like
this particular character I I was I wish he that guy went
with this other girl and not her because she Ritziko
deserves so much more I'm just gonna say she she deserves so
much more she does not deserve he does not deserve her and
then I never watched the season after that because I was so
sad that like she dumped that other This flight search seems
like it's taking forever.
I grabbed it because my original flight got canceled.
I think we're almost there.
Oh, please, my eyes are up here, Miss Retsuko.
It's nice to meet you.
I'm Retsuko.
I took some time off from work because I have a really
stressful job.
Oh, yeah.
She said OL, by the way.
I was hoping a break from the office would be good for me.
I keep thinking about my boss and the work that's probably
piling up.
I'm getting even more freaked out.
No!
I don't know anyone I'm playing, but they seem to all know
each other.
Don't worry, Retsuko.
You can know me!
But my eyes are up here, by the way.
They do seem unusually friendly, though.
You already gave me gifts?
Oh my god, where's my gifts?
It was nice meeting you.
It was nice meeting you, too, Retsuko.
Okay, I'm done.
If I can't talk to Pompon Perun, then I don't care anymore.
Alright, I'm ready.
tomorrow.
This is such an exciting opportunity for my...
Okay, I don't care about her either.
It's not every day you get invited to open this door on the
Tropical Island Resort.
And theme...
Who told... Who talked to you, my melody?
No one asked for you, melody.
And theme park.
We're here to support you, my melody.
Oh, I can't say no.
oh thank you you're both so kind you know my invitation to
big adventures park was mysterious i'm sure it's perfectly
ordinary island though i can't wait to land are you still
talking to new friends or do you want to meet them after we
land i'm ready to land take me down i want i want my new
village do i keep being rude i didn't ask her to talk to me
She butted into the conversation.
Andy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think Karomi actually has episodes of her show on the
Haukitty and Friends YouTube.
Oh my god.
I love how each Sanrio character actually has their own
YouTube channel in Japanese.
And they actually upload cover music videos too, which is
funny.
I'll go get you a slice.
Just wait for me at your seat, okay?
Look, I want to make new friends.
but not, but not Melody.
Not some of the people here.
I get to pick and choose which Sanrio kicked through.
I want to be friends with.
Is there a fucking oven in the plane?
That should not do well with the air pressure.
So delicious.
As long as I input the settings right, of course.
Okay, let's see.
Why is there an oven on the plane?
Is that safe?
Is that...
Beep, beep, boop, beep Error, please break to send an error
Please press bake to send an error report Error Oh no!
What did Kitty do?
What did you do, Kitty?
Who put an oven on the plane?
Oh no Free food By a second rule I can't turn it off More
cakes keep flying out everybody hold on your lunches it's
about to oh my god the cake caused turbulence how it's too
much cake there's the island we're so close oh no there's
smoke coming out of the plane are we just gonna fucking oh
no that's more enough is enough i've had it with these cake
oh God, it's a cake's on the plane.
Wait, it's cake's on the plane.
What?
Everyone take some balloons.
We're gonna have to jump.
Okay, don't worry.
Single file, everybody.
Single file as we jump off the plane.
Wait, but is the plane gonna crash?
what year is it these motherfucking cakes on this
motherfucking plane don't worry these balloons will keep you
safe i promise hang on tight okay i hope so whoa i see
balloons jump jump jump okay yay oh shit oh shit i didn't
know what this I can move.
How do I jump and float to the...
Guys.
Whoa.
Maybe I'll hit one ring.
I did it.
Guys, I did it.
I got a ring.
I got one.
That's all that matters.
Guys, I got one.
Okay.
Do you happen to notice where...
How can we find it?
her no i didn't care i didn't care chocolate cat found one
of the resorts map and scanned it here i'll send it to you
okay just open the map on your phone and look for my melody
you need help finding do i have to find her find three
strawberry the guy in light will show you where to go just
follow it oh my god i have my own iphone within my ipad when
you find her would you give her
yay gosh this looks so weird that you're naked
thank you thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
airport no one should be lost on an island with unhealthy
snack wait where's my snack though you gotta find my melody
okay oh wait there's something over here what is this I got
game ticket oh my gosh there's gonna be video games here but
this i got mystic stone there's so much stuff here what's
this strawberry crate i mean she has to be here this is
literally her house is she just no oh my god okay we're
gonna be nice to melody she owns a store guys we have to be
nice to her now because she has a store guys okay guys we
need to have like She's like, oh, she's like the Tom Nooks
in Animal Crossing.
What is this?
The strawberry crate.
Happy landings?
Oh, they're like active quests.
Okay.
Where's the...
I need a fine...
Track progress.
Show guide, please.
I'm baby.
Tell me where to go.
Okay, it is right.
Okay, she's over there.
Okay.
You can do this.
that oh my god they have a discord too and everything holy
shit all right oh my god thank god for the guiding light
thank god is that her she's over here ma'am where's the
namoro where's the real star would you like a strawberry
miss melody a gift that's so thoughtful i know all me i
found it just for you Try gifting a strawberry to me.
You know, like, oh my gosh, she's so demanding.
Better than yellow paint, I know, right?
Oh my god.
I already, you need it to be wrapped.
This is why I don't like Melody.
She's so...
She's so high maintenance.
Karomi wouldn't care.
She'd just be happy that I fucking got her a strawberry.
I didn't need to wrap it for her.
So demanding.
I wonder if I...
like suck up to her and she'll like give me discounts for
her store be mean she literally told me to wrap her gift for
her she knew i was gonna give her a strawberry giving gifts
is a great way to make friends i try to pick gifts that
everyone likes for example how a kitty likes fruity things
like an apple pie that's mario likes jokes and gags so i'll
give him a okay these are another people i want to get close
to each time you give someone someone like your friendship
with them will continue to grow they'll also give you gifts
in return which can be very useful try learning what
everyone likes and becoming good friends oh and he only gave
three gifts a day to each friend does that make sense yeah i
understand now by the way have you seen anyone else since
you arrived in the plaza that's where everybody is great
lead the way oh my god No, this isn't...
Oh, I got flower!
New friend!
You're now friends...
You're now new friends with my melody.
Okay, follow me, miss.
Don't worry, I have the guiding light, so I won't get lost
ever again.
Hello, hello, kitty.
I got melody here.
Wait, I don't see Karomi.
Where is she?
Where's Karomi?
By my calculations, Half-party seems to be absent.
No!
I just realized all the ones I hate are on this side.
I'm missing...
Yeah, wasn't it Retziko?
Yeah, what about Retziko?
They forgot about Retziko?
They're like, isn't there one more person?
so fucked up.
Retsuko is so much more famous than you pochi.
Hello?
Can I help?
Oh, oh dear.
She didn't make it.
Who is that?
A ghost?
I believe it was a hologram.
Sophisticated technology but deteriorated.
She's so smart.
The island has only become more mysterious since we arrived.
I'm going to set up camp.
We need a base of operation to discover what's afoot and
find everyone.
Oh my god, he's like Sherlock Holmes.
That's a good idea.
We should split up, gang.
Look for clues.
When does this become Scooby-Doo?
Split up, you should never split the party.
Batzmaru, you watch too many scary movies.
I'm serious!
There's no one here!
There's not even staff!
Don't stop slandering my boy, Pochuk.
Bro, he started it.
He didn't think Retsuko was important enough, but he
would...
But Retsuko is, like, more famous than him because she has a
TV show.
Where's his TV show?
And don't say, like, he was in the Hello Kitty show, because
it literally says Hello Kitty.
He was a guest star.
I was supposed to be stabbed.
And look, there's my new story.
They specifically said I need the furniture and decorations
in my shop.
Maybe we can fix up the cabins for our own visitors.
And that looks like a place where I can make food for all of
us.
All of us even mean?
Fine.
I'll go check by the beach.
Maybe there will be a snack bar or something.
Hello kitty and friends He's in the friend section Doki Why
don't you see if my melody needs any help It must suck to be
melody Because like her sister Is Karomi?
No, Karomi's not sister Karomi's just a really good friend
Right?
Or was it cousin?
I don't know, the lore keeps changing I don't remember if
that Karomi is supposed to be like Cousin, sister or a
friend anymore But like, Melody's just jealous because
Karomi ended up being more popular than her.
Alright, help Melody at the gift shop.
What do you want help from?
Welcome to the grand opening of Small Gift Bag Smiles.
That's a terrible name, Melody.
I was like, what?
Did I read this correct?
Like, did I read or is that store name correct?
correct small gift big smile tropical edition it was sweet
of you to come and find me earlier i'm sure you'll find the
rest of our friends too and when you do i just have the i
have just the thing i want to see what do you have melanie
they see i brought welcome gifts for all our friends when
you find them you make sure to brighten your day with these
gifts oh i'm an excellent gift giver i am thank you so much
this will be great way for you to make friends with everyone
here.
Pay to win!
Okay, the moment Cinemoro gets here, I'm gonna fucking spend
so much money so that Cinemoro will be my friend.
You know Cinemoro's a guy?
Just so you guys know?
And he has a girlfriend, too.
He had a girlfriend.
Soon.
Each time you give someone you like, your friendship with
them will grow.
they'll also give you gifts in return which can be very
useful try learning what everyone likes and becoming good
friends oh and you can only give three gifts a day to each
friend are you ready to find your friends and give some
gifts oh i'm ready i'm ready lovely here are the gifts i
need delivered please be people i like hello kitties welcome
okay that is Oh, and don't forget to tell everyone that
small gift, big smile, tropical edition is open for your
furniture.
Mm-mms.
Little too.
I like how they have the, uh, they have the, the frog
cupboard, which is similar.
Hell, a kitty, chocolate cat.
That's, oh, it's basically everybody.
This is like the, the frog chair in Animal Crossing.
But now, but now it's like a fucking shelf.
All right, let's go.
We gotta find them.
I like the froggy mirror I mean it's pretty cute Okay, Hello
Kitty's like right here She's like right here Jump, jump,
jump Oh, if you hold it Wait, what shop is this?
Is this a coffee shop?
Is Hello Kitty the pigeon in this game?
Oh my god, can I sit down?
Something seems to be missing Oh, the umbrella Don't worry
Kitty I'll do your job for you Wait, how do I put it down?
How do I something's missing but how do i put it down uh
collection no i look at my bag oh
okay oh it doesn't matter all right never mind i can just
think about it i think karomi and basmaru are kind of shut
your mouth
need no man no there's no way there she deserves so much
better there's no way i refuse to let her date batsmaru
there's no fucking way oh good i could see sario game i was
worried about to see something like that sonic movie maker
game guys they give us super chat thank you thank you
there's no way batsmaru no way there's no way there's i
refuse to believe that they are a couple.
He is so beneath her.
How does she even...
Oh, I got tofu!
Nice.
New friend.
That's the year and now.
New friends with Hello Kitty.
Yay!
Wait, what does Hello Kitty want?
Isn't this the cutest cafe?
It's wonderful!
She has standards!
Karomi has standards!
standards.
It's even stocked with fresh supplies.
I think I work.
Look at the fucking Sanrio popularity character contest.
Do you know where Basmaru is in the popularity rankings for
Sanrio characters?
It's so low.
Karomi is the top five.
She's a top five gal and she deserves a top five man.
Anyway, so we can feed our friends when we find them.
Since you're here, do you mind me with something?
What do I have to do?
What do you want me to do?
These padded holders are missing some umbrellas.
I found one across the street and I have a feeling they're
scattered around the resort.
Ideally, I like for each table to have an umbrella.
Would you mind seeing?
Oh yeah, that's easy.
Here I come.
Don't worry, I got you, look, kiddies.
This thing...
No!
She does not have a crush on Basmaru!
I refuse to let her have a crush.
Oh, none of this is working.
Kitty, how can you run a cafe if none of these were...
Oh, wait, they work!
Oh, I don't have...
Is that a heart?
No, that's a strawberry.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, I can, like...
Wait, I have to make my own dessert?
That's fucked up.
Keep going.
I refuse.
Karomi go beneath her standards she deserves the top five
guy for a top five for a top five Karomi I don't know what
kid what I don't know what creature she is but she deserves
better all right I like how like um oh wait let me put this
oh there's a picnic basket can I steal it No, I can't.
And they can't steal it.
Wait, which place is this?
Okay, so, like, you know how, like, there's, like, Hello
Kitty has a boyfriend, and his name is Dear Daniel.
And she also has a sister.
I forgot her sister's name, because no one really, because,
like, no one really cares about her.
But, like, there's, like, this, like, Hello Kitty lie on the
internet, where if you look up Dear Daniel, it's, like, what
was it?
They say, like, Dear Daniel, Daniel was, like, oh, my God.
what the lie was i remember like googled it her name is me
me no one cares about me me no one cares she's just hello
kitty okay maybe i care a little bit because she has a
yellow bow yes hello kitty has a boyfriend his name is dear
daniel dds the double ds uh everyone forgets me me thank you
i forgot tuxedo sam existed also it's a new vibrant purple
cloth i can make good use of it
I got thread.
Don't worry, I'll never come back to the store, Tuxedo Sam.
I don't need clothes.
Yay.
All right, this is the last time you'll ever see this guy.
Greetings and salutations.
By pure chance, I stumble across the perfect location to
open a clothing emporium.
Egg planet.
Oh, yes.
Hala Kitty also has a cat called Charming Kitty.
Don't think too hard about it.
don't think she she and apparently like the creator was like
she's not a cat like the creator of hello kitty was like
hello kitty is not a cat to like justify her owning a cat um
i plan to keep myself very busy until the rest of our party
joins us uh in fact i already had my first customer i had an
honor of outfitting chuckle cat in explorer wear that was
both stylish and Yeah, it's like a goofy Pluto situation.
I'll be honored to serve as official clear for a merry band.
Let me guess, do you need something?
Well, normally I wouldn't pose, but I'm facing a rather odd
dilemma.
I need assistance in displaying and tailoring my designs.
I'm quite at loss without clothing stands to aid me.
Would you mind searching around for some?
If you guys didn't just jump off the plane, you would have
all your stuff.
I may see some outside.
Okay, I think, I think, like, the villagers here are a
little stupid.
Like, they literally jumped out of the plane and was like,
We don't need our luggage.
All right, we got one clothing stand.
Oh, let's grab some strawberry crate.
What's this?
What is that?
What is this?
Funny how that...
a comic where did you come from batsmaru what's that over
there what where the fuck where did he come from monster
envy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you part
of how kitty's lore is that she is british oh yeah yeah by
the way she's british i used to watch the hello kitty show
and then like i had like i remember like my parents like
when vcrs were a thing we taped like Hello Kitty episodes
and stuff I would always, oh wait no not tape I had like
Hello Kitty tapes of like the one with Hansel and Gretel
with Hello Kitty and then the Hello Kitty and friends Hello
Kitty Hello Kitty I mean you're trying to set a trap for me
a comic book store would be the bait well I'm gonna hang
around here for now okay alright so wait I'm already friends
with basmato oh he has like he's a fisherman okay i okay so
that means we can fish in this game too of course basmato is
the fisherman all right basmato i have a gift for you uh
give small gift big spell is open i'm totally there whoa my
melody gave me some water balloons i like how i think i love
how like um this was like melody's gifts but then all the
villagers are like oh my god doki thank you so much for
giving it to me oh no one one popped all over me is that a
crab in the background does this count as a prank from my
melody i think it's funny that that they're like wow doki
thank you for the gifts that came
on magnet.
Okay, three paper and a magnet.
Okay, what do you want, Botsmodo?
Since the water balloon I got from My Melody, first, I want
to try and get another one.
I bet we could make one with some of that rubber around
here.
What?
Will you collect... What?
Rubber grows on trees.
Usually they grow up on hills, but I also saw one by Choco
Cat's tent.
Here, take this plan okay okay we're gonna grab find some
rubber water balloon crafting plans don't we need like a
process to like fucking make rubber once you have the rubber
we can make at the crafting oh there it is we got a crafting
table too prank preparation stolen present valour garlic
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you where's red
circle What's in the model?
I don't want to talk to these people.
When can I kick them off my village?
Just like Animal Crossing.
When can I force them out of the village?
So I can have my optimal village.
Oh my god, what is that?
Is that B?
Well, I can't catch it yet.
Because I don't have any.
bug net.
Okay, let's grab all of this for fucking tuxedo sham.
Where's the... There's like one more, but where is it?
What?
There's like one more somewhere here.
What the fuck?
Where's the last one?
It says it's like around here.
But like, we're around here.
Is it like here somewhere, like hiding?
No.
I'm so confused.
Oh well.
Let's see.
Who cares about what he wants?
Anyway.
What's that?
Is that bug?
Oh, it's right here!
Oh!
Guys.
Guys, this is not a children's game.
It's actually pretty difficult.
Here you go.
I finished a mission.
This is a very difficult game, guys.
Three cheers.
We're the champions.
yet provided a valuable service.
That's me.
I'm currently in your debt.
Yay!
I got another magnet.
Woo!
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, I can trade items for clothes.
No.
We don't need clothes.
What we've learned is that we do not need clothes.
We are perfect, guys.
Look at us.
Oh my god, that hat is so cute, though.
Imagine if I had that hat.
hat on no but we don't need it guys we're so beautiful
already we're wild and free chat wild and free all right oh
he's like the sporty type veggie bread wait he's a
vegetarian is that canon is pochaco vegetarian canon my
melody really knows what i like Okay.
Strawberries.
Alright.
I like how someone's like, no!
My Puchaco lore!
The deepest lore.
No!
The fact that Puchaco's vegetarian, it's ruined!
Hey, have you seen a little egg throughout the...
No?
What?
What little egg?
look over there there's one right now where Gautama there's
multiple Gautamas but what if we took a picture maybe one of
our friends will know here take my camera get to where you
want to take a picture press the camera tool and then you
can adjust the camera feel free to strike a pulse while
you're taking a picture by using the remote when you're
ready to snap that pic just press the camera again oh my god
it's I love Guttama.
I talked about this before, but when I was, like, younger, I
bought this little cute Guttama thing where you open the
fridge, Guttama would, like, come out of his egg.
So you put the Guttama thing in the egg carton, like, in the
egg drawer.
And then when you open the fridge, Guttama will come out of
his egg and will be, like, close your door!
Like, in Japanese, and it's so fucking cute.
And it does that, like, every time you open the fridge so it
reminds you to it's like there to remind you to close the
fridge and everything it's so fucking cute oh my god there
he is gutama oh my god wait no not like this okay i need to
take a selfie with gutama oh my god gutama give me a sec i
need to take a selfie i love you gutama no oh my god it's so
difficult to to lie myself next to you i need to take a
picture one of my many oh she's insaniel kutama please
kutama I want to face the camera okay all right let's see
what's this oh my god I could have just done that okay nice
um yes yay accept oh that's so nice guys no it's like they
give me one freebie and then i'm hooked forever that's how
they get you they give you a freebie and it makes you long
for him he died no
into the picture you go you absorbed him into the picture
What's this?
Science seems to have weird egg creature on it.
Maybe...
Oh, it's Gautama!
It's Gautama!
Alright, Gautama.
What do you want?
Oh, no.
I'm not giving you anything.
What do you want?
Pachaco.
Hot potato.
Nice pick.
Let's get everyone over here.
Hey, everyone!
Look at this sick-ass picture!
The Toki Tuck!
Guys, you know, it was pretty good, though.
It was...
Gutama stole.
What's going on, Pochaco?
Game of the Year, that's what's going on.
Take a look at this picture.
Do you know what this is?
It's Gutama!
They're called Gutama!
Strom, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
You fool.
You fell for the classic plunder.
I first came across to them in France when I was training to
be a professional baker.
Utama?
Huh?
Crazy.
It's whole race I know right what it's funny they look like
little lazy things who don't shut your mouth except I spot
him in every corner of the island did you know I take an
island jog every morning I do now look I want everybody to
enjoy the island's rugged challenge and stunning views you
can't take a vacation while pushing yourself to the max
right and gutama can be anywhere right so i'll cut you a
deal you can have this camera but only take pictures with
different gutamas all over the island make sure you strike a
rad pose in your picture i'll give you a hint to start i saw
gutama hanging outside my cafe oh my god easy easy no
cheating let's start with six gutamas that's a half a carton
it has to be a different one in each picture.
Can you handle that?
I was born ready.
I love him.
I love Gutama.
I like how I was like remembering now of like how nice it
was like you never say I love you.
And I'm like that's not true because I'll say I love you to
Gutama.
You can always return for the sign just to check how many
you've taken pictures of.
Gutama deserves it oh my god i love him so much i love you
kutama
he's so cute kutama okay i would always have like sanrio
phases the great kutama number 10 the fuck is that what the
fuck is the great kutama okay let's grab this got mystic
stone oh my god there's like fishies i can like fish did i
drown oh whoops oops almost drowned all right quest what
about to do the right tools power what the fuck is all oh my
god i did not realize there's so many quests here okay power
up the gate taco too okay we're gonna find choco cat we're
gonna do the main quest i don't care about the side quest
honestly where's my guide yellow paint time yellow paint
take me to choco cat yellow paint this is so nice yay oh
what's this oh that's the crafting table for the rubber when
we have to craft the rubber for Batzmado.
What did I get?
Oh, I got a blank book.
I can make a story out of this.
I heard you can play multiplayer.
I saw, like, the multiplayer, like, panel.
Hello, Choco Cat.
Oh, my God.
Are they on the other side of that?
All right, here's your gift, Choco Cat.
What's this?
An old photograph?
My melody found while cleaning up the shop.
Incredible!
This might have been taken on the island forever and ever
ago.
Where is this location?
Please.
Open the door.
I need a five-star tomorrow.
Open the door!
Yay!
Small gift, big smile.
Okay.
I'm setting this gate to see how we might be able to open
it.
I think I'm missing friends.
have landed behind this gate to find them you have to oh my
god how do we open it how do we open it give me karomi at
least karomi i was just studying the ruins on the door where
is retzuko too no one ever said where retzuko is the door
will open or a power source more specifically yellow power
crystal see here it looks like the ancient plans were some
kind of power crystal sensor a power crystal sensor
is correct.
We'll need three sticks and three magnets to create the
pirate.
I have two.
I have two magnets.
I've got what we needed.
I don't actually.
Oh, I do.
Do I actually?
Wait, do I actually have it?
I was lying.
Oh my god, I do!
Let's go.
JK, I was not lying.
I got the crystal sensor.
The fabled power crystal sensor.
Look.
Typical magnets equals magic.
Guys, science is practically magic, chat.
You use the sensor, type the button, and select it.
The closer we are to a yellow power crystal, the faster...
What is this Chaos Emerald?
the faster it will pulse oh my god it's like those like
metal detectors okay am i doing it correctly oh it's pulsing
right when i get closer to one how do i know
chocolate cat how would i know what the fuck what the fuck
is this what what is that What did I spray out?
Hey, look, there's a butterfly.
No.
Where are the crystals?
Oh, it's like a little mini-game.
Don't worry.
I drown.
Guys, don't worry.
No.
Where is the crystals?
Am I stuck?
Oh, I got stuck and it kicked me out.
I can jump, but like...
No, Choco, where is the power crystals?
Please.
I just want to find Kuro-Ming.
Oh.
It's beeping.
It's near.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
by where can it be oh it's here perhaps that we work
together we'll be able to open it oh you stand over here and
i'll stand on the other side that's right we did it oh my
god is this where is this mining wait there's mining what
the fuck is this oh my what we're mobile gaming for real is
Oh my god, there's fucking dungeons in my Hello Kitty game.
This is Minecraft now.
It's Minecraft time.
I got stamina apple slice.
Oh my god.
What the fuck am I gonna do with this?
Oh, I'm climbing.
What am I gonna do with a stamina apple slice?
Yay!
Yellow power crystals.
Okay, we got... Oh, wait, I can glide!
Can I die?
Oh no, there's a...
I got stuck on the pillar.
The game was like, trying to kick me out of the pillar.
Oh my god, we're mobile gaming for real.
How many power crystals do I need?
Did it tell me?
I don't remember if it told me.
Okay.
Did it tell me how many?
I'm all set.
Okay, there's no...
the accounted for like to wait who the fuck is this guy
who's this guy hello is he just gonna stand here is this a
statue oh it's a statue i thought it was a real person oh
choco cats dead whoops oh there he is
it's like where did he go choco cat where did you go Stick.
I'll grab some stick.
What was this?
Sand Dollar.
Oh my god, it's like Animal Crossing Sand Dollars.
Better than World of Warcraft.
100% better than World of Warcraft.
Butters was right.
Oh, that's a sprint.
Okay, we don't need to do that.
We're not going to play that game.
Look, this is important.
We need to find Karomi.
Please start beeping.
Start beeping.
is the queen oh my god where is it it's not beeping anymore
oh it's right here it's up here yeah this game is actually
real i think the funniest part for me about this game is the
fact that it's like the same type like the same name as as
the cell puck reference they did that on purpose they had to
do that done that on purpose just for the memes the other
thing is that i can't believe JP agreed to it because like
this is like NA's idea you know it's obviously like NA's
idea to do it so like I'm like more surprised that JP agreed
to it because you know you know it's it's self-park the fact
that they agreed to have a reference like to like self-park
in the end is actually crazy where the fuck is it It's so
vibrating.
Sit down here.
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
I found it.
It has to be this dungeon.
No, please.
Open up.
I need a sea.
I need a rescue Kuromi.
Oh, no.
What the fuck?
There's a puzzle?
Okay.
no oh no no okay we gotta figure this out guys oh i know i
know i put this here guys guys these puzzles are very
difficult children this is why this is not a kid's game chat
this is exactly why this is not a kid's game a normal child
would not be able to figure this out unlike me
up yay yay another pile here I got another yellow power
crystal let's go thanks ChocoCat for not helping oh no I
need to figure out where the last one is where is the last
where's the last power crystal oh but chest chest time
flower you know i was like looking at wait is this oh should
it be this it should be this right was i here oh it is i
fucking knew it i knew it is it though it's not what do i
how do i get Oh no, it was just a normal chest.
Okay, this doesn't matter.
This doesn't matter.
It's just a normal chest.
Wait, where's Choco Cat?
Where did Choco Cat go?
It left me.
Choco Cat?
Oh, it's this way.
Just a moment?
Where is he?
Take a look at that.
What, the tree?
Oh, it's over here!
The power crystal sensor indicates a yellow power crystal on
the island over there.
But this bridge will not sophisticate carry us across.
My melody is quite handy.
Perhaps she would be able to help.
Why don't they get her to help?
She's gonna ask...
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
She's gonna ask me to get her something.
Like, she's not gonna do it for free.
She's the Tom Nook of Sanrio Halle Kitty Island Adventure.
He doesn't do shit for free, and I don't think she does it
for free either.
A broken bridge?
I may be able to help.
I bought a lot of drilling materials in the strawberry
crates when we came.
I haven't found them all yet.
See, I told you.
If you can find two strawberry crates...
Oh, I have those already.
Never mind.
I already have it.
Perfect.
Give me those to me, and we'll look at that bridge.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God I picked up everything.
strawberry crates.
Alright.
Yay.
Oh, I have, like, fucking eight.
Oh, you found the crates!
Nice work!
Let's go to that broken bridge and get it fixed up.
Let's go.
My Melody Avatar palette.
Oh, I don't need that.
I'm already the perfect color.
I'm the dragon colors.
Alright.
Come on, Melody.
Go do the work now for me.
So I can, so I can, like, be friends with your cooler,
hotter slash sister slash cousin.
All right, Melody.
Build that bridge.
Let's see what we can do with this.
Oh my god.
She's so handy.
Wow.
There.
Ta-da!
All fixed.
Wait, what is that?
What's what?
I got three sticks.
from the extra, I guess like she she like couldn't finish
using all these sticks how did she do that oh wow it's
wonderful what you don't see the infinite potential in this
place wait is this my new home it just needs some tender
loving care and it'll become a beautiful house when you fix
this place up with three more strawberry crates once you
have them use the sign outside of the visitor cabin to start
repairs Where's the visitor cabin?
This one?
Oh.
Oh, some more friends will show up!
Oh my god!
Yes!
Yes, I have it!
Please!
I have it!
Let's fix this place up!
Please!
So the moro!
Please come visit!
Isn't it beautiful?
It feels so much better that we worked on it.
Together!
These home can be found all over the island.
Decorate and customize them to attract visitors like dear
Daniel and Mimi.
I love how like those were the example.
The better you decorate their taste, the better.
Oh, I just need to decorate it to look like...
Look like Sonomoro's house.
Oh, you fucking...
This is how they get you.
Fucking...
Melody was like, come to my store and buy the furniture for
the ones you want.
Oh, my God.
You bitch.
I'm so sad.
This is how they get you.
What do I get from this, though?
We.
Oh, shit.
I went the wrong way.
Wee.
Oh, shit.
I went the wrong way again.
Guys, I don't think I'm going to fucking do this challenge
correctly.
Wee.
Unless.
No.
Oh, hey.
I got a crate, though.
You stopped yourself.
Guys, I was very mad.
I might.
I might have got a little toxic.
I can't believe it.
I can't.
I can't believe this is how she's getting me.
No.
Oh, no.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, he's right here.
No, you can't swim for longer than two seconds?
Okay, here you go.
Oh, no.
I'm, like, trying to remember how to fucking get back.
He's going to want those wacky digits on the back of the
card.
I knew it.
I knew there was a pay-to-win feature.
You actually have to pay-to-win.
get your favorite villagers it's like the amiibo cards all
over again it's like the ebay store for that fucking cat and
the animal crossing
yay i got the pyre crystal that's messed up it's run no tom
nook is nothing compared to my melody I need I can't I need
that I need Sonomoro Does she has Sonomoro furniture She
doesn't even have Sonomoro furniture In order to get friends
and family To visit our island we need to decorate The
visitor cabins here at Taze And in order to decorate Cabins
you need furniture Luckily you can buy furniture here Of
course Of course I can What Should I buy?
Well, different visitors have different tastes.
Why don't you open the visitors app on your phone?
There you see what dear Daniel.
I don't want dear Daniel.
Why are you pushing dear Daniel onto me?
Are you calling Daniel?
Oh my god.
Find dear Daniel's likes on your phone.
Bro, I don't want him on my island.
all right where is he why does that why why daniel i don't
want him what the do i look at oh visitors here you go oh my
god who the fuck are these guys oh grandma this is your
grandma why would i get your fucking grandma, Melody!
Melody, work on your own relations with your grandma.
Why do you have to pay for your grandma's furniture?
I was like, who is this?
Like, my Melody's grandpa, Tam?
There's more of the penguins?
Tam and Pam?
Who's... Oh, okay, he's tuxedoed younger brother okay Pam is
the younger brother okay your whole family I like daddy I
like it's like her whole entire family why do I need a
fucking buy furniture for your entire family melody not even
Sam I know right what happened to Sam okay dad Daniel, what
does Daniel must be in Seaside Resort to be near Halle
Kitty.
He's like, you gotta be near my girlfriend.
Alright.
Dear Daniel is a charming, sophisticated world traveler and
photographer.
Boyfriend to Halle Kitty.
He has a keen eye for...
Wait, he's a fucking photographer now?
Must have three pieces.
I like how he's just like, I just want furniture.
And must have mama's apple pie.
Oh yeah, because they're like, they like apple pie.
I remember that.
I can't believe she's making me buy furniture for her
fucking entire family.
That's so messed up, Melody.
Did you check?
Yes, I did.
It looks like Dear Daniel likes Mama's apple pie and three
pretty pieces of N furniture.
Why don't you get something for him now?
Okay.
I guess I'll get a Kawaii alarm clock.
All right.
Here you go.
Tuxedo Sam's Younger Recolor.
Carlix, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kaz, yeah, happy with just three pieces of furniture.
Yeah, he's a guy, all right.
Yeah, as long as he's close to his girlfriend.
And also, like, um, and also just has three pieces of
furniture.
Doesn't need to be a bed.
Just, like, furniture.
That's all that matters.
Okay, we need a...
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
That Sanamoro isn't in the guest list.
TV, PC, and PS5.
I love that there's like this Reddit where it was like, you
know when it's a guy's room or like a guy's studio apartment
due to like the pictures of like the pictures of the fucking
apartment or studio apartment and it's literally like it's
like there's nothing on the walls or there's there's
sometimes nothing on the walls and it's just a bed yeah it's
in males living spaces okay we gotta we gotta put the yellow
gears on look if it works it works exactly that's all that
I'm so sad that I might have to buy a new iPad.
I can't...
I can't open the resort gate.
I was like, I can't, guys, I can't keep using my dad's iPad
for this game.
Well, now we can explore the inner sanctum of the island.
I'm so happy to have been a part of this.
Thank you so...
Oh?
Oh my god, it's a robot.
look the gate is projecting a holographic image I saved
money from not like gamer subs was like don't worry Doki you
don't have to pay for the prize pool anymore and now I'm
spending the prize I'm spending the money which I would have
given for the prize pool for a new iPad I was like yay I got
to save money and I'm like well gotta spend that business
expense on the iPad tree where am i hello hello whoa you're
sensing it oh no it's her situation all over again oh no
chocolate cats falling in love what algorithms were you used
in your coding do you use neural networks to process
information But Largus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I never bought posters from my college dorm until one day my
mom got frustrated and brought me more.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Oh, sorry.
I'm Choco Cat.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Top Hat.
Yes, Top Hat.
So, do you live here?
We only just arrived on the island not long ago.
I don't know.
I can't remember anything.
Nothing at all?
That's odd.
Well, except I was floating way up high.
I saw that too.
You're floating over the island.
Yes, but what were you doing up there?
Did you...
Did your plane cake make your malfunction like ours?
What happened to that plane?
Is that plane gonna crash somewhere?
We never went.
back to the plane situation well maybe inside the theme park
we'll find some things that will help you like more crystals
would you like to join us i think grrr is i hope he's okay
me too chaku cat me too let's go in maybe we can find a way
to help him all right time to help him it's at the did you
come from okay i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick guys
but i'm gonna make sure to hide i'm just worried about afk
i'll be right back i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick
chat i'm back sorry i didn't need a massage guys i'm back
all right all right chocolate cat my father you gotta find
kauromi all right the whole park i can't wait to see what's
out there There's so much more to explore.
I hope you'll be able to find the rest of our friends and
deliver their welcome gifts.
And I hope that we can find out more about our new
holographic friend.
Yay!
Can I...
Can I find Karomi?
I can't...
I just want to find Karomi!
Whoops, I dropped an orange.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Decorate the cabin.
No, we are not decorating anything.
Who is this?
What is this?
Oh my god, there's like stamina.
I just noticed the stamina.
Wait, I see her!
Guys!
Guys, we gotta climb!
I see her on my map!
Oh my god.
Oh, the frames.
What did I get?
That was trap.
Oh my god, there's a frog, too.
Oh, I can't swim, guys.
She's on the mini-map.
Guys, we're gonna find her, guys.
We just gotta figure out how to get across.
How to get across.
Oh my god.
This entire area is like...
I'm not decorate I don't care about Daniel I just want to
find Karomi They're like please Please Doki Just decorate
I like how the game is just like Decorate please We just
need you to decorate I don't care about Daniel Just give me
Karomi.
Oh, hey.
Flower.
Ooh, swamp muller.
How the fuck do I get across?
I will find you, Karomi.
Oh, wait.
There's a chest, though.
There's a chest.
Give me a sec.
I got distracted.
Yeah.
I got pants.
Guys, you think the game is telling me something?
No.
Guys, it's so funny, the game gave me pants.
I wonder why.
No pants for this dragon.
This dragon doesn't need pants.
Oh, coconut.
Oh, no.
Did I softlock myself accidentally?
No way.
Okay, we'll figure out how to get around this.
Dude, don't worry.
Don't worry.
We're gonna figure out how to get around it.
Oh, it's like...
Can I climb up this?
Oh, shit.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
There's no way.
There must be a way for me to get across, right?
Oh, yes, there is.
Oh, thank God.
I didn't fuck up.
Oh, Lily Padleep.
Okay.
Karomi!
Oh, my queen!
Oh, my God!
Boo!
Gotcha, didn't I?
You got me good.
of course you did she's here sorry but i can't resist giving
a good jump scare i was born on halloween so it's in my
blood i guess that makes sense of course you're always right
my queen pleased to meet you by the way i'm karomi you might
have met on the plane
got some jump by the way oh me too i was so excited to see a
spooky out for myself but i didn't realize everyone was
behind me do you know if my melody and everyone else yeah
they're okay they're fine who cares about them it's all
about you girl it's all about you wow okay well if anyone
landed around here i'll track them down no don't leave don't
leave me kuro me here i got you a gift it was all me not my
melody i got you oh mg it's the latest book Sugar
sweethearts forever see oh my gosh she's just like me my
melody knows I'm their big no no I knew that you're that
biggest fan could owe me could owe me could owe me please a
akasupa you could owe me say my name please could owe me
don't leave I love you
was born on Halloween what do you expect you need something
I have a question i just want to talk to you she's just like
me um any tips about gifts what do you like hello kitty i go
no no no what do you like i don't care about the others i
mean have you seen anyone look better on the beach not the
fucking beach where's pom-pom put it in okay oh my god i got
to meet my queen my oshi guys guys i met my oshi guys wait
wait Kuro-mi!
Kuro-mi!
Meet and greet!
Oh my god!
Kuro-mi!
No!
Please!
I paid so much for the- Kuro-mi, please look at the camera!
Okay, wait, okay, maybe like I'll stand- I'll stand here!
I'll stand here!
It's okay!
So it looks like we're- It's okay!
I'll just stand here.
It's okay.
Yay!
Wait, what is this?
Okay, wait, wait.
No, she has to be normal.
And, um...
Oh, low battery mode.
That's not good.
Let me...
Wait, wait.
Wait, let me charge the...
I do have any charge.
Don't worry.
I didn't realize I was playing for so long, guys.
I didn't realize.
I got so absorbed.
I got too into it, guys.
Give me...
I do have a charger, so do not worry.
Guys, do not worry.
I have it right here.
Let me just get the wrong one.
Okay.
All right, here you go.
Pull this all the way over here.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
I need it to be...
No, why aren't you closing?
no don't worry guys it'll be fine it'll be fine i just need
it my cable is a little too short wait for me oh
my god am i charging i don't know i have the ipad on my lap
now okay okay let's see oh my god oh my god oh my god guys
guys i got a photo of my oh she i got oh my god we got a
photo of my oh she guys so happy i love her i love kronomi i
love Oh, hey, yeah, it's me!
It's me!
You're getting the 12.9-inch iPad Pro.
It's 1.5!
And before tax rip, you're seeing money starting the fun.
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, yeah, I don't know why it's here, but it clashes
with the spooky vibes it's got going.
Is that a button on the mailbox?
What does that mean?
Delivery service.
Let's see.
Activate the mailbox.
Whoa.
Is this fast travel?
Come on, me.
Why are you telling what's glowing?
I never did that before.
Then again, I never yeah, I never bought it to touch it.
I wonder why it's glowing.
Anyways, you came just in time.
I was hoping to send over this pumpkin to my melon, but I'm
right here.
Come on, She'll never appreciate you like I do, Karomi.
Karomi.
I'll deliver the pumpkin.
You don't do any work.
Your hands are not meant for work.
Cherry seed pumpkin.
Thanks.
That's a big help.
It's okay, Karobi.
Don't do any work, Karomi.
I'll do it for you.
My queen.
No, no.
They were girlfriends.
I refuse.
Konobi.
Okay.
An old mailbox.
Someone must know how to use it.
Wait.
How do I deliver this?
Deliver that pumpkin?
No.
Do we need something?
I have a question.
What's up?
Would you break up with Melody?
Konobi.
Please.
She doesn't.
She doesn't deserve it!
Guys, how do I convince that Tokey just got Rizzi, thank you
for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
How do I convince her that she's how do I convince her?
I need her to let I need her to like break up with Melody
she does not she does Melody does not deserve her she
deserves someone better like a certain bird person you need
to let no no I rather her be single she doesn't deserve
Everybody, no, none of them matches my standards.
None of them match my standards for Konomi.
No, I can't believe it.
Alright, let's see.
What do I need?
I need a delivery service.
Give my...
I have to walk over.
Discover Sinamoro's speedy delivery.
Sinamoro, where are you?
Wait.
Sinamoro?
Wait, how the fuck do I use it, though?
What the fuck?
Wait, the Cinnamoros Beatty Surf?
How do I use it?
Excuse me?
Someone must know?
Who's that someone?
Who?
Sorry, Kuromi.
Oh, hey, there's an apple.
Oh, I can't get there.
Sorry, Kuromi.
Cinnamoros.
Cinnamoros, my first.
Sorry.
The moment I find Sonomoro, I don't need you anymore.
I just...
I need to find him.
He's my first...
He's my first Sanrio love.
Karopi!
Hey!
I can't believe we jumped out of the airplane!
I'm Karopi in case you forget.
Nice to meet you, Karopi.
Do you know if everyone is okay?
I didn't see anyone else land with me.
Um, they landed in the resort.
Oh, okay.
That's good to hear.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't wait to tell Batsmaru about the jump.
And hopefully get some friends to help fix this place up.
Where the fuck is...
Oh, hey, here's a gift.
I'm just gonna chuck it at him.
I don't care.
Well, a guide to island critters.
isn't my melody great yeah she's so great here since you
came all this way to deliver that gift let me help you out
there are plans to craft slippers which let you swim oh wait
i actually really need that i've been like drowning myself
here's what materials you'll need where's like the crafter
guys i need to find cinnamoro guys i need to find cinnamoro
so i can take a picture
Where is it?
Where's Sonomoro?
Sonomoro!
Where are you?
Maybe Sonomoro will appear when I go back to my melody!
Oh my god, I got it.
He'll show up when I- He'll show up when I see my melody.
I believe.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Alright.
Okay, there's the gate.
My melody.
Oh wait, I need to craft the flippers.
I really need the flippers, man.
Oh, I can just craft it.
Oh, yeah, she's also great.
Yoki growled.
I mean, it's...
She's so great.
Yeah.
First, I have mail for you.
My melody.
Melody.
I have some mail.
Please.
Please look at this mail for me.
Oh, okay, let me...
Oh, it's because I never...
Did I never activate this?
No, I did.
So I need to...
I'll just give it to her here.
Here's her fucking mail.
Ah!
Snowmower!
Oh, my God!
He's so cute!
He's helping!
Look at the...
Oh, my God!
Snowmower, no!
No!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Look at me, look, yes, look, look at me, oh my god, he's
looking at me, okay, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, I need my
camera, no, I don't want to shop, I can't see, oh, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
all right, all right, and then, and then, all right, oh my
god, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no No, no, no.
And not this one.
Not this one.
Wait, cancel.
Cancel.
I can't stop.
I can't stop waving, please.
I'm so embarrassed.
Sunamon, no, look at me.
No!
Look at me.
Yes.
Look at me as if you admire me, Sunamoto.
Okay.
Okay, and then I'm gonna get the camera.
Oh, my God.
He's looking at me, guys.
Guys, he's looking at me.
I'm, like, his biggest fan.
And then, um...
Oh!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, wait, wait.
Actually...
Oh my gosh, which one?
Maybe like...
Dancing?
No, no, not dancing.
Maybe...
Yes!
Accept.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Look!
Oh my god, I'm your biggest fan!
I don't care about anybody else in the world.
You're so cute!
Look at his cute outfit!
Sometimes when there's a cloud along my route to deliver the
mail I we could get rid of Melody and guys photoshopped
Melody out of this photo guys guys I need somebody to
photoshop her out she's ruining the picture sometimes when
there's a cloud along my route to deliver the mail I give it
a quick of course you do are you looking for yes yes i have
a question how can i help any tips about yes what do you
like i don't care about her i don't care about melody dear
daniel bro i don't care about daniel id can i get a vibe
check you haven't discovered enough of the island determine
your island vibe score just yet oh my god what there's a
vibe check i guess you can get your present i don't fucking
guess so a what check a vibe check give me one second i'll
be right with you just sign here oh my god he's like the
amazon delivery guy in this game here you go thanks sonomoro
oh do you know sonomoro yes i do i'm your big as fan i'm
your number one donator on your youtube channel lol a nice
lollipop a nice picture of cinema and a dragon thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you hey there please i'm your
number one donator thanks again for delivering the pumpkin
i've been i've been a 10-year membership i have a 10-year
membership to your channels in the model i'm in your fan
club It's hard to get spooky things at the Seatside Resort.
Can you do me a favor and deliver this coastal podded plant
to Karomi in the...
Okay.
It's something that will be hard to get out of the spooky
swamp.
Yes, I gotta bring this back.
I'll tell her I got her that plant.
I don't want to impose, but can I...
Oh, yes!
Yes, please.
Follow me.
Of course, I'll follow you anywhere.
Let's go.
Let's follow.
Let's follow what our first Gen Real love.
Hello, Sanamoro.
What do you want to tell me?
Hey, when did...
I've seen one of these in the spooky swamps.
That's fantastic.
You already come across a fast...
Oh, it is fast travel.
I knew it.
Throughout your journeys, you will come across these
mailboxes.
Upon activating the fast travel mailboxes, mailbox, you'll
have the ability to be delivered back to this spot at
Cinemoro speeds.
Oh, cool.
No more walking back for me.
Now, please activate this mailbox.
They're not activated.
Yeah!
You know that mailbox was found, you found in the spooky
swamp?
Since you already activated, you can return there at any
time.
Just select your map and select the icon.
Then select a destination.
In this case, please choose the spooky swamps.
Oh!
Where did he go?
I was gonna take a picture with you!
Oh my god!
Oh, I can take a picture with all of them.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta take a picture of all of them.
With all my Oshis.
All of you guys.
Look back.
Oh my god!
Yes!
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
And then I wanna...
I'm gonna do...
And then...
Get the fuck away from their bug.
And then I'm going to be like, yeah.
Oh,
which one?
Oh, my God.
Me and my Oshis.
Me and my Oshis, guys.
I paid a lot of money for this meet and greet.
Who's my cameo?
Oh, fucking course, it's in Amaro.
It's in Amaro.
And then Kodomi is my second.
You're my second.
Oshis, don't worry.
I'm not creepy.
I swear.
She's by a second one And then Kutama's the third Kutama
It's like And then it's like Sunamoro Kutama And And Pump
Pump Pudan No problem in here I'm not going to mention
Melody Oh it's so cute Friendship ended with Kutomi Now
Sunamoro is my best friend Doki probably hidden thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you i mean whatever oh my
god she's just like me guys i know like okay look look i
love i love karomi but like you never forget your first and
cinnamara was my first
you you never forget your first so how do you like the that
was amazing cinnamara tomorrow oh it's my pleasure when
you're out there on your adventures just make sure to keep
an eye out for any more milk of course do you want to live
here do you do you want to do you want to pray ship oh my
god to the motto i got you some gifts what do you like you
like bonus you like those puffs and then you like coffee
chocolate and salt okay guys maybe he'll like live here now
where is it who the fuck are these oh my god oh my god
there's like his girlfriend and then there's oh there's baku
there's baku and then there's alright we should like not we
should we should not get his girlfriend on the island we
should which one was it this is his girlfriend mocha the
leader of the cinema mocha is like an older sibling to the
group sometimes bossy but often sweet she also likes to show
off the flowers in there we're not getting his this
girlfriend's not gonna be in uh in this wait that's a sister
what the fuck is the girlfriend that's the sister i thought
that was the girlfriend oh shit guys this is how little i
care about his girlfriend i was it chifan it has me chifan
right because this is a cappuccino that's cappuccino or was
expresso is i an espresso or no he does he has a girlfriend
this is like this is there's literally deal dear that you
cannot say that you cannot say this is a kid's game we're
fucking dear daniel is in this game and they've been like
pushing daniel at me it's so hard like literally says
boyfriend to hello kitty no he does He does have a
girlfriend.
It's true.
Is it Chiffon or Expresso?
This is how little I care about his girlfriend.
Oh, Chiffon.
Fuck her.
You don't deserve him.
It's the pepiest member of the Cinema Angels.
Sports fan is always eager for a lively game.
You don't deserve him
Turkey chill he had a girlfriend.
You're right guys.
He had a girlfriend.
We're never letting his family live on our island guys Never
who's this guy part of This guy knew I've never seen this
guy before our 301 welcome to the tomato for me when I'm
parasocial
look look i'm not gonna say that like i'm parasocial to
sinamoro and karomi i'm not gonna say that but like they
deserve so much better
they deserve more than what they can give them i know
somebody that can give them what they want
Oh my god.
Are you gonna live here now, Sonomoro?
Are you gonna live in my village?
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
Sonomoro is gonna live in my town.
Oh my god.
What are my other missions?
I've not cared about my other quest ever since I found
Sonomoro.
Reharm the spooky swamp.
Reach Karomi level 4 friendship.
Okay, Karomi, what do you want?
Karomi.
Karomi, what do you want?
I'll be level 4 friendship.
Friends with you.
Kadomi.
Do you want pumpkin?
Here, here's a pumpkin.
Oh, you are?
Here you go.
Oh, a light stone.
Okay, that's not pumpkin, but...
Level two!
Oh my god, I have the Karomi Avatar palette.
Wait, what is Sinamoto one?
Sinamoto!
Sinamoto, so I can be my Oshi's colors.
Sonomoro!
Sonomoro is gone!
No!
I left the way!
It's okay, I can be number two Oshi colors.
How do I change my colors?
They never taught me how to...
No!
My Oshi!
Do you want a pumpkin?
I have a pumpkin.
Here you go.
You ran away.
It's over.
Do you want another gift?
I have another one.
Here, take all my pumpkins and take all of it.
Friendship crows.
I'm level three.
I'm level three now.
Do you want another gift?
Oh, wait.
Can I give three gifts a day?
No!
I can't love bump.
Kodomi.
Kodomi, please.
I know you set a limit on super chats.
Kodomi, I used my super chat limit, Kodomi.
I'm going to make a new account so I can give you more super
chats, Kodomi.
It's so Kodomi.
Kodomi, please take my pumpkin.
Please, I show you my pumpkin.
Kodomi, please.
Kodomi.
I'll make a new account, Konobi.
Please take my pumpkin.
No.
Konobi.
I love Konobi.
Dark Lady.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Konobi, no.
Don't turn me off.
I'm here to give you my support.
I don't.
understand
was that ghost why is there a fucking ghost who are you
who's a hat it's like new hat I meet the eye oh my god
they're all like hat ghosts or something who the fuck are
these people okay okay the order is like it's it's Sinamoro
Kuromi Kutama, Pampa, Perret, and then Retsuko.
Retsuko's the...
Retsuko's the other one.
It's on the...
Where are the hats?
I don't want to fucking exchange hats.
Oh yeah, I can swim now too.
Where's Retsuko?
We gotta find Retsuko.
Where is she?
The Ghost Tour Gallup?
Oh, I don't care about that enough.
We gotta find Retsuko.
Romi's about to fall a restraining.
Waiter.
I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so tired.
It said I'm...
Yeah!
Yeah, he was!
I took a photo with him earlier.
Blood brain.
Go brain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I took a photo.
I took a photo with him.
With my Oshi.
With my Tommy Oshi.
Guys, I'm lost.
Where am I?
I'm actually lost.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's just a rock.
I was like, what happened?
I got fucking eaten by the rock.
Guys, I'm so out of place that the map stopped loading on my
top left corner.
The map is just gone on the top left corner, guys.
That's how lost I am.
There's no more maps anymore.
Where am I?
I'm in the gemstone mountain?
How do I get out of here?
The map is just white.
There's like no areas anymore.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we're safe.
We're safe now.
Okay, the Dune Lagoon.
Okay, we were here.
We were here.
This is where we found...
This was a spooky forest.
Oh, there's fast travel.
Fast travel.
Yeah!
Where am I?
I'm the ghost tour ride now.
Alright.
We need to find...
We need to find Pom Pom Puddin.
He's like somewhere here.
We found the spooky swamps.
But, uh...
We can't find...
Where's Pom Pom Puddin?
Pom Puddin!
Okay.
There's a castle over here.
Maybe Pom Pom Puddin's over here.
Oh no, this is the maze.
Can I climb up?
I beat the maze, guys.
i like how you can just climb up and like guys i did it i
beat the maze oh these are like extra houses that like other
villagers can live in where are you pop pop put in pump pump
put in
bro he's not he doesn't even show up in the maps he's just
gone I just want to farm pump pump put in Oh wait I got
stuck I missed the Kutama No and I missed the Kutama Oh my
god I'm a mess I'm a fucking mess right now Oh you can't
just cheese the maze You actually have to do the maze I
thought I could climb it He's off the grid He should be here
It ended on this side!
Oh my god, hat!
There's a hat on one of them.
Wait, I'm gonna steal this hat.
Wait, is this like a game?
It is, right?
One game ticket for one...
Grab as many ghost apples.
I can't blow my nose, can you say.
Oh my god!
How many game tickets do I have?
I can do this.
I can't be difficult.
Plus two apples.
Grab.
Do I have to come back to him?
Don't worry.
Look at the speedrun.
Look at this fucking speedrun.
Wait, there's a power crystal here?
Wait, there's a power crystal here.
Oh, chest.
Oh, I can't open the chest.
I have to keep grabbing apples.
Oh, no.
Wait, 16?
Don't worry.
I'm not lost.
I'm just gonna spam.
grab was that chopsticks what is that what the fuck is that
oh it's kutama guys oh my gosh kutama oh i can't take a
photo no i try to take a kutama break and the game was like
toki please there is another game you have to play i was
like but kutama the kutama no the kutama fucking
Great job, here is a prize.
I still got a prize, though.
I got a blue brain hat.
Oh, I got a hat.
And I got five apples.
Wait, I want to wear this hat.
How do I wear this hat?
Hat time.
How do I wear it?
Is this?
Where?
What does it look like?
Oh, my...
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
oh my god okay it's a little freaky it's a little freaky
we'll milk make it work we can make this work mojo jojo
jagoon gooon guys we can make it work guys can i like look
at this there's Pompurin.
Oh, there's another world here?
Wait.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Wait, there is another world here.
Where is he?
Oh my god, Ritiko!
I like how Pompurin is like, where is he?
He's over there?
How do I get there?
What?
He has his own store that's like two 200 miles away holy
shit guys the main plaza is like here guys why are you all
so far away they're lost in the fog okay now that i know
where he is i'm gonna go back to the resort plaza we're
gonna we're gonna meet ritzuko first it's bigger than tears
the kingdom map i still don't know how to change my
appearance i want to be my oshi's colors But, like, I don't
know how to change my colors.
Okay.
I have a nice hat now.
This is a cute hat, not gonna lie.
This is me as an introvert.
Oh.
Let's pick this up.
I'm gonna pick this up, though, real fast.
Yay!
Alright, we're gonna swim through Retsuko.
Retsuko, don't worry.
Oshi number five.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry, Retsuko.
about me from the others.
Wait, am I going the right way?
There's an island here for food?
What is that?
Do you guys see that island on the map?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna swim over.
I'm gonna swim over to you, Retziko.
Wait, oh, that's cute and exposed brain.
I know, right?
Don't worry, Retziko.
Saving private Retziko.
But there's a store right here i think on my map it showed
like some fucking store oh wait nice fast travel we actually
need that yay anything for my oh she's ritziko i need a
photo need a photo what's this oh nothing else just sorry
sorry i got a little distracted let's go i'm coming i'll do
it i'll around the world for a photo of my Oshir.
I love you, that's the goal.
Oh hey, there's a house here too.
Oh wait, there's a do you have a hat?
We can swap hats.
Oh, you don't have no hats to exchange.
God damn it.
He has no hats for me.
I got a die patch?
Where did I get that?
What?
Okay, where is she?
She's over there.
let's go i'm gonna climb up this wall it looks like i can't
climb up this wall just to see you let's go climb up this oh
i got soft locked into that wall how do i get to you let's
go
i don't understand it won't let me climb this mountain to
like convince them of my love i'm gonna climb oh i'm
figuring it out i figured it out oh my god here i come
that's the call i'm coming over don't worry my other oshi
this is how dedicated i am to the cause oh god okay
oh wait what's this flower oh my god maybe she'll like that
maybe hello let's go is someone there yeah i'm over here in
the bushes should be able to help me oh my god of course i
can so you'll owe me forever let's go remember my name i'm
dokey bird
hello thanks for helping me out there oh my gosh of course i
jumped out of cinemaro's plane This was Sunamoro's plane.
Oh my.
Sunamoro, I love you, man.
But don't ever drive a plane again.
Now you owe me forever, Retziko.
And this debt can never be repaid.
I landed in the bushes and got stuck.
Oh, where are my manners?
I'm Retziko.
Oh my god, nice to meet you.
Oh no, my luggage.
No, don't cry, baby.
I must have floated off course as well.
I'm gonna stay here and look for my belongings.
If only I had friends, I'll be your friend.
One mini-crete ticket for pom-pom pudding, please.
Thank you for the super chat, Zechro.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
It's a go.
Okay, okay, all right.
You, you.
Yeah?
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna move you.
All right, here you go.
We're gonna take a picture.
okay you and me oh yes you look like that and then i want
reticle i want you to i want you to make um make this
expression for me all right reticle i want you to make this
expression and then i i will make i will make this
expression ha ha or like no no no actually no what do i do
And then I'd be like...
I'd be like...
Wait, I need like a good wood.
Yes!
I'd be like, you owe your life to me now, let's go.
Let's go, my friend.
You're on vacation, let's go.
Can I help you?
I'll let you relax.
Girl.
So here's a gift that I've given.
found just for you bro melody didn't give her a gift melody
never made her a gift that's so fun don't worry i'll be your
friend who cares about her oh my god she didn't give her
anything don't worry here's another sinna bloom i got you
girl i got you so kind i'll be your only friend reticle be
your only friend you don't need the other people on the
island you just need me nice i received another dough yeah
i'm level two i got the reticle avatar palette nice okay now
we gotta now we gotta find pom-pom put in all right where
where's pom-pom put in pom-pom put in is like right here
don't worry travel across the world your parents
look look melody never made her a gift that's so up just
because retziko is newer is the newest one of okay she's not
even a new addition too she's not even a new addition and
melody never even made her a fucking gift in the first place
i can't believe it she deserves better and i'm the better
i'm the better okay i got red power crystal what the fuck oh
there's there's a fast travel let's grab that fast travel
real fast all right nice we're almost there to pump on put
in i think where is he yeah he's like to our right look she
made a gift for pump on put in oh no oh no thank god i love
how whenever the game knows i'm stuck like it helps me out
pump on put in don't worry i'll save you i'll be a hero i'll
be a hero but no let me okay okay we gotta how do we get
there wait how do we how do we get to that side no no this
island won't fucking forbid me from seeing my other oshi i
will meet all my oshis what the fuck is this what is this
what's the sad what the fuck mysterious oh all right I guess
I'll never be able to read that oh my god mountains are
fucking denying me of meeting my other oh she that's so
fucked up let's grab wait 20 what I'm literally charging it
what do you mean oh it's because like okay don't worry guys
although i know it says like 20 wait i can climb this i'll
brute force this i'll brute force this come on let me climb
this no no it's too far it's too far away no please let me
meet my my other oh sheep before i lose all the batteries i
don't know how i'm stuck
no i'm trying to figure out how to get to him i'm literally
walking around the mountain oh yes
yes okay i'm on a time limit now guys whoop is it gonna kick
me up oh thank god okay all right we figure out how to get
up oh no i'm stuck again oh my god i unlocked the map let's
go let's fucking go we don't end until we meet our other oh
she okay wait wait i'm gonna recharge stamina i figured it
out recharge the stamina right here okay we're gonna do this
that's right yes
the things i do for the people i love this is it this is it
oh my god i see him on the map guys let me meet him this has
to be him this has to be where you live pump up put in i'm
floating down don't keep doing the sequence breaks oh he
runs an ice cream store we've been looking for you i had
plenty of time for a nap i'm pump up put in by the way You
never go in front of me and my O-Shees.
I'll always find a way.
I think I saw you in my dreams during my...
That wasn't a dream.
Maybe this is a sign I should go back to sleep.
This non-functional ice cream boat is a great nap spot.
But I do wish I had a close.
Let's become friends.
Let's become friends then.
Friendship and naps.
The best thing...
Oh my god!
I'm Pum Pum Puddin's friends!
I'm in.
I'm actually in.
Here you go.
I'm in.
Of course Melody knew I'd need a tasty snack after the
plane.
She's so thoughtful, isn't she?
She's so me.
Oh my god.
You mean I'm so thoughtful.
Oh my god, he gave me a banana.
Friendship rose.
I'm now friends with Pum Pum Puddin.
Alright, we gotta take a picture.
We gotta take a picture.
we gotta take a picture look at the look at the camera yes
and then i'm gonna be like yay or maybe like not a stalker
not a stalker by the way we did it we found all our oh she's
guys we fucking did it Yeah!
I wonder, like, who else can we have for visitors?
Was it just...
Oh, there's, like, Papa Purun's mom and dad.
And, like, sister?
Wait, Pump...
Macron is a golden retriever who styles herself to look like
a Puro.
She wears in a...
Oh, my gosh.
I didn't know about Macron.
Okay, that's so sad.
But Retzuko has, like, no visitors.
Like, that's...
That's, like...
Oh, no.
It's a little fucking sad.
like everybody has like a visitor except for except for like
let's go is that like the girlfriend
must be in gemstone mountain to be near pom-pom put in is
this the same wait is that the girlfriend does pom-pom put
in have a girlfriend no he had a girlfriend he she's He had
a girlfriend.
Not anymore.
I'll be your only neighbor.
Bumum put it.
Don't worry.
Look, I'm your colors.
I'm your Oshi colors.
No one told me there was so much walking for this trip.
Do you need anything?
Can I talk to you?
what's up any tips about this kadopi it really seemed to
okay i don't care about kadopi i only care about you i only
care about you all right guys guys i think this was a this
was a good place to call it oh my god
i i met all my oh she's
i think i think this is a good place to call it here i met i
met all my oh she's today and i think i'm gonna i want to
leave it on a high note of leaving all the oh she's the ipad
agrees uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
how to be parasocial why don't you don't understand i do it
for them you like that meme do it for her do it for them do
it i got my meme in greek guys Yay!
I met everybody!
Meet and greet accomplished!
You don't understand.
They are my oh, she's.
I got a photo and I got, I got all, I got my meet and greet
and they, they accepted my gifts too.
I had a great time though.
This game seems, but I wish it wasn't region locked.
surprised that it's region locked.
I thought this was like, I thought it would be like outside
of, like people outside of NE can play it.
Maybe people can EU people download Hello Kitty Island
Adventures?
Cause like I know like for Asia, you can't apparently.
Cause my dad's Asia account couldn't download Hello Kitty
Island Adventures.
That's so weird.
But it was so good.
I could tell me on my oh she's oh my god Oh, there's
multiplayer.
I didn't bring up the multiplayer because I was worried.
I was scared.
How do I additional parental permission?
We need, you can change this.
Online features enabled.
Oh!
Invite code.
I can send an invite code or something.
Wait, what is my invite code?
Apparently there's like multiplayer.
I'm like looking through it.
There's multiplayer and everything.
How do I change my colors?
I'm looking through this right now.
now.
You guys can't see it, but I'm looking through it myself
just in case.
Nep, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cute stream.
Oh my god, I got a dress!
Oh my God.
Guys, there's daily rewards and everything.
How do I change my colors, though?
It doesn't tell me how to change the colors.
Oh my god.
Can they give me stuff if I if i can oh my god wait wait jl
jl wait okay we actually don't i'm not gonna say what the
last one is all right never mind i don't know like how it
even talks to me if i have somebody join my room never mind
i didn't see the last two i didn't see the last two
elephants i can't worry I was like, wait, but like what I,
what would it look like if somebody tries to join my room?
I almost, guys, sorry, I got too excited.
I got way too excited.
I was like, oh my god, we can like, you can like give me
free stuff in my world.
Oh, that's fun.
I'm glad I got to finally fully experience Hello Kitty
Island Adventure.
for reals now I'm so happy I've always wanted to play this
game and uh you tell me it's okay I didn't I did I did I
didn't say out there was like two more letters that I didn't
say out so thank God you guys I closed the game too I I
closed the game just to be sure just to be sure I didn't
accidentally fuck up I closed the game well oh my god I
can't believe it I met Kodomi I met um I met Kodomi I met
Sunamoro I met Pumperin let's go and Kutama I don't care
about the other ones I met I can't believe all my favorite
characters I were like locked behind quest that was so
fucked up of course like the ones I don't care or the ones I
have to communicate with first like i met all my oh she's
yay hey guys i had a great time playing i hope you guys had
a great time watching even though it was just me fangirling
about my my sanrio oh she's
um but i had a great time hanging out with you guys i'm
sorry it took the stream was an hour with all the stuff
going on i'm so sorry the stream was an hour delayed but now
now now i know now i know so i hope you guys still had a
great time watching even though it was an hour late um but i
always enjoy streaming for you guys everybody uh yeah no
fuck apple though oh my gosh apple is so fucking convoluted
for no reason like it was so difficult just to log in like i
couldn't as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay
up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you
guys next time everybody bye guys